well many children in the valley don't
have the luxury of waiting for a present
to be delivered the holidays are a time
of struggle that's right well it's here
local non-profits like don't blink
motivation and UBC Sports Foundation can
really step in yeah photojournalist
Henry takai takes you to the Pearson
Community Center in West Las Vegas where
Christmas came early
have over 150 RSVPs that we have sent on
the application process where they said
what what was their wish what was their
Santa wishlist and how old they were and
so those items we selected we shopped so
we have at least over 150 kids coming
the price of everything is so much
expensive I went last night to go
shopping and I saw how much everything
had increased and I said oh my God this
is what the parents are experiencing
when they're in here shopping a lot of
us are single mothers so you know we we
do our best you know we try to buy
things but it's just so expensive right
now people can know that they have
people that care even if it's a stranger
you know that they do matter I love it
it brightens my heart I give out
literally throughout the year but coming
back you know to you know West Las Vegas
to give back it definitely raised my
brightens the heart very excited she
came an hour early eight eight yes it's
hard when you work and you can pay the
bills but not really get a lot of gifts
this is DeMar this is King this is
London and this is Mariah like Barbie
dolls cars yeah they're really easy to
please so basically just toys underneath
the tree this one Roman is expecting
toys he's expecting toys I like cars I
think so I'm pretty sure we have a bike
it doesn't really matter what I get I'm
gonna be great for what I get and it's
all about like you know love not gifts
or money it's about All About Love
nowadays it's more important to um think
about the kids when it comes to the
holidays you want to put a smile on your
kids face children nowadays are so
thankful and they're thankful for for
the smallest things